[Music]
a big song for that yes it seems after
almost two years of being cooped up many
americans are making like the beach boys
and planning an epic vacation for 2022 a
survey from the travel website expedia
finds that 68 of americans are planning
to go big on their next trip well with
many searching for destinations like
rome bali london and paris
so how could you plan a big trip amid
such so much chaos and uncertainty
surrounding coveted restrictions flight
cancellations and more our travel guru
peter greenberg is here to break it all
down peter is this really a good time to
take a major trip it actually is
airfares are at historic lows they're
never going to get any lower than they
are now number one and all the
indicators are that about 3.4 billion
people are going to travel this year
more than a billion crossing an
international border not at the top of
the 2019 levels but getting pretty close
to it
and you think travel insurance makes
sense oh you have to have it but here's
the problem you have to have you have to
have it but here is what kind of
insurance do you get because during the
pandemic it was the number two largest
level of complaints because peop most
people watching the show book their
trips online and you can't complete the
transaction unless you either opt in or
opt out of the insurance you don't know
what you're covered for and worse you
don't know what you're not covered for
and so many people discovered that on
page 95 of that website which you never
got to there was that clause that said
oh by the way we don't cover for
pandemic they essentially bought
worthless insurance but peter yeah but
most trips don't get canceled so why why
would you recommend that people bet on
the bad thing happening ah people
themselves cancel the trips because of
cohen so if the airline cancels the trip
you're covered by the u.s department of
transportation saying you'll get a
refund but if you cancel the trip you're
out of luck yeah that's that's i hadn't
thought of it that way what happens if
you make the trip you're out of the
country you know now you have to test
negative to come back in you test
positive and you're out of the country
what do you do well that's interesting
now there's some insurance policies that
are changing their deal because they had
to pivot the market demanded it so there
are two companies alliance or alliance
has one kovac is a new company that
really will take you if you're testing
positive they'll cover you and they'll
fly you home they'll cover you to do
what they'll they'll pay for your
expenses while you're being quarantined
and they'll get you home so of course
you got to read the fine print yeah
because there are exclusions for age
certain countries they're not going to
cover you for that vacation in syria
right but the point is all seriousness
they will have a different policy
language now which is desperately needed
any particular places you have in mind
and and maybe an idea of how much it
could cost well right now the caribbean
is way out of control i mean everybody
had the money you know bashed in there
they they're now going down there and
they're getting a thousand two thousand
dollars a night that is not exactly
where you want to go right here's the
deal there are 196 countries in the
world about 180 of them you can go to
now mm-hmm pick a place where none of
your friends want to go
my mom what country is where did she
want to go she went to mexico
about a week ago she loved it and that
was the number one destination during
the pandemic but what countries are
getting it right when it comes to
handling kova to to keep you safe well
the first thing is their vaccination
levels have to be high so take a look at
ireland most of that country is
vaccinated now as if yesterday they
relaxed all the testing restrictions
anybody can go because their vaccination
is so high right what is trip stacking
that's what people are doing to protect
themselves they're making multiple
reservations on multiple destinations
knowing that the airlines got rid of
those draconian ticket cancellation fees
so you can do that and knowing you're
not going to lose your money if one trip
cancels or you cancel it you get to the
other one so it's like it doesn't sound
bad to me
i can't i can't imagine the airlines are
too excited about that right no but you
know what they they canceled the ticket
cancellation fee so you can do that and
not lose your money so peter where's
your next trip where are you going
newark
okay
not so bad recently named the dirtiest
city in america actually hey
i love newark i do but that was that was
one of the talk of the table options
today
it's lovely this time of year peter it
is beautiful good to see you in the
studio nice to meet you